we begin this half-hour with what may be
a significant shift in the gun control
debate Las Vegas shooter Steven paddock
used a bump stock attachment to turn his
rifles into virtual machine guns the
National Rifle Association now says it
is open to the idea of regulating that
accessory some Republicans in Congress
agree as does President Trump
joining us from our Washington bureau is
Ed O'Keefe he's been covering the story
for The Washington Post he's also a CBS
News contributor ed good morning good
morning guys Alex welcome back thanks ed
so how significant is this ad this what
seems to be a shift in in terms of gun
regulations it was significant this week
Anthony in that you saw Republicans so
quickly at least expressed an openness
to discuss it usually after these
tragedies you see Republicans pretty
quickly say it's too soon to judge it's
inappropriate to suggest that this is it
I was struck then almost immediately you
saw some pretty senior Republican
lawmakers realize that this obscure
device that virtually nobody knew about
certainly not at the Capitol we're
willing to at least talk about it and
say maybe there is something that needs
to be done here whether it's regulated
by the ATF or we do something in
legislation you did see some Republicans
like the Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell say absolutely inappropriate
to discuss legislation refused to take a
position on the issue but there are
enough Republicans out there who could
at least compel themselves to hold
hearings and debate the issue which is
farther than we've gone in several years
and what's the medium-term prognosis
here though I mean I think there's an
acknowledged asymmetry in terms of this
fight given the fact that gun rights
advocates usually are in this for the
long haul and those pushing gun safety
reforms sometimes don't stay that there
is an asymmetry talk more about that
yeah you're talking about the idea that
in the immediate aftermath of a tragedy
there's a lot of interest in political
will but 30 60 90 days out the only
folks that are still concerned about
this are gun owners who are totally
opposed to changes in the Second
Amendment that dynamic alex has started
to change you've seen these groups prop
up since the Sandy Hook tragedy in 2012
that now on a regular basis are putting
pressure on lawmakers to take a position
to enact legislation that would make
changes you've got two bills right now
in Congress just when to make concealed
carry laws that have reciprocity across
state lines and another that would allow
silencers on certain weapons Republicans
had planned to vote on these things
actually this week this past week
delayed those these gun right these gun
control groups the groups that are run
by former New York Mayor Michael
Bloomberg there's a large group of
mothers who've been pushing for changes
in gun laws for years have continued to
put the pressure on Democrats and some
Republicans and you know the Senate is
off this coming week that group was
telling me yesterday they plan to try to
find especially moderate Democrats who
in the past perhaps have been skittish
about this and try to get them on the
record to say that they support making
changes in gun policy and what is it
about bump stocks that suddenly has even
groups like the NRA you know willing to
consider regulation well two things
first of all did you know what one was a
week ago no sir I think 99.9 percent of
Americans didn't and that's the point is
that they realized suddenly this obscure
device could cause such incredible
carnage the other was frankly just the
scope of the death and and the injuries
that were caused in this shooting and
John McCain and other Republicans just
said look Americans are horrified they
the idea that somebody can do this with
a device that none of us knew about is
something that we have to pause and
consider and so whether it's done
through changes in ATF regulations or
legislation in the coming weeks in
either way they realize that this is
something that at least has to be
discussed all right ed O'Keefe in
Washington this morning thanks ed take
care